حديث الرئيس الوزراء البولنديه عن اعتزام
بلاده تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات ما يصلط
الضوء على كميه ونوعيه الدبابات التي
ستزود بها اوكرانيا او تزود بها من دول
غربيه مختلفه الدبابه البولنديه بيتي 91
تعتبروا نموذجا محدثا من الدبابه الروسيه
72 حيث اجرى تطوير المحرك والدرع واليه
الاطلاق الدبابه البولنديه تضاف الى قائمه
الدبابات الطويله المقدمه الى كياف وهي
لبرد اثنان الالمانيه
وايضا دبابات لكلر الفرنسيه في غضون ذلك
اعلنت مصادر الدبلوماسيه ان فرنسا
وايطاليا تقتربان من وضع اللامسات
النهائيه لامداد اوكرانيا بمنظومه الدفاع
الجوي سام تي التي تصنعها سويا يذكر ان
هذه المنظومه يمكنها تعقب عشرات الاهداف
ومن صواريخ البالستيجا واعتره 10 منها في
وقت واحد طبعا مقابل ما تسميها اوكرانيا
بحلف الدبابات الكبير فان الجانب الروسي
يمتلك ايضا عددا كبيرا من الدبابات
المتطوره وهي تي 90 التي تصنف من افضل
الدبابات في العالم وفقا تقرير نشراته
مجله ناشونال انترست الامريكيه اضافه
لدبابات تي 80 وتي اثنان وسبعون ايضا